llega el momento de un nuevo repaso
económico en france 24 para ello
contamos con nuestro compañero luís
méndez luis bienvenido de nuevo vamos
con rusia y ucrania como estamos yendo
todo el día porque hay sanciones nuevas
hacia rusia verdad así es esta fue por
parte de eeuu canadá y la unión europea
que en el caso del bloque y no incluye
la prohibición tanto en vladimir putin
como de sergei lávrov de ingresar al
territorio comunitario lo que sí prevé
esta acción es el congelamiento de
activos de ambas personas en el espacio
del bloque europeo adicionalmente josh
introdujo el primer ministro de canadá
además de sumarse a las sanciones
destacó que su país apoya la exclusión
de rusia el sistema internacional de
pagos swift por su parte eeuu se sumó a
la unión europea para sancionar a
vladimir putin y su ministro de
relaciones exteriores con la prohibición
de viajar a la unión americana pero
putin en este caso si podrá asistir a la
sede de las naciones unidas que tiene su
sede en nueva york pero escuchemos las
palabras la portavoz de la casa blanca
james y aun después de la conversación
telefónica mantenida entre el presidente
biden y la presidenta de la comisión
europea ursula von der leyen en
consonancia con la decisión de nuestros
aliados europeos los eeuu se suman a las
sanciones planteadas en contra del
presidente y putin su ministro de
relaciones exteriores lávrov y los
miembros del equipo de seguridad ruso
pero rusia viene siendo afectada por las
sanciones de este 2014 después de la
anexión de crimea uno de los países que
comenzó esta reacción fue canadá que se
retiró en un primer momento de la
comisión económica
intergubernamental canadá rusia la unión
europea entre otras cosas restringió
capitales rusos en sus mercados al
tiempo que estados unidos previó visas a
algunos funcionarios rusos de acuerdo
con el ministerio de finanzas de rusia
en noviembre de 2014 el gobierno había
reconocido pérdidas anuales por el orden
de los 40 mil millones de dólares es
debido a las sanciones pero para
contrarrestar la sanción los
especialistas consultados por la
publicación británica y vice
aunque rusia comenzó a protegerse
mediante una menor dependencia del dólar
también redujo préstamos e inversiones
del extranjero y buscó su propio sistema
de pago internacional luís qué objetivo
concreto tienen todas estas sanciones
desde entonces han estado dirigidas a
presionar a moscú para que desista de
algunas decisiones pero para conocer más
detalles nuestra compañera daniela
blandón previamente conversó con
gabriela siller directora de análisis
económico del grupo financiero base y
esto fue lo que le dijo penal de cuentas
yo creo que trata no de hacer repensar a
rusia vladimir putin a que repliegue en
las pocas que salgan de ucrania ahora
una sanción que se han lavado mucho que
podría utilizar occidente sobre rusia es
pues quitarles el swift esto es tú sabes
el sistema mediante el cual se pueden
hacer transferencias internacionales
rusia sabe de esta importancia e
inclusive pues se estima que si oxidante
llega a desconectar a rusia del swift
pues el pib de rusia pudiera caer
alrededor del 5 por ciento y verse en
problemas pues ha respondido que si
hacen esto pues deja de dar petróleo y
gas a europa lo cual también sería
terrible bueno louis rusia es proveedor
de petróleo y gas natural a muchos
países especialmente de europa cuáles
podrían ser los más afectados no cabe
mencionar rodrigo europa sería uno o
algunos países de europa serían algunos
de los más afectados por su gran
dependencia del gas ruso básicamente por
un mayor uso de este elemento en
detrimento del empleo del carbón para la
producción de energía las exportaciones
de gas a rusia en la unión europea
alcanzaron los 153 mil millones de
metros cúbicos y representaron el 38 por
ciento de las importaciones de gas en el
bloque alemán ya suspendió la aprobación
de la certificación del gasoducto nord
stream 2 es que cuenta con una longitud
de más de 1200 kilómetros y requirió de
una inversión de 11 mil millones de
dólares para llevar gas de rusia hasta
alemania al igual que el norte es 31
transportaría 55.000 millones de metros
cúbicos de gas al año y representaría el
70 por ciento de las exportaciones de
alemania por otro lado rusia como
productor de petróleo ha sido de ante
las decisiones de los pp y los
integrantes de la organización para la
estabilidad de los precios del petróleo
muchas gracias por este análisis
realmente interesante de todo lo que
puede conllevar la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania hasta aquí el repaso a la
información económica sigan conectados
con nosotros en france 24
[Música]